So C sections are super prevalent in this country,
and I think, in my mind,
the number one cause is,
oh, we need to induce you.
You're 40 weeks,
or you're 39 weeks,
or you're old,
your baby's too big,
your baby's too small.
Oh, did you know that babies
are more prone to stillbirth after 39 weeks?
Cause of the ARRIVE trial,
which is a total fucking BS.
Pitocin is a known
drug that causes fetal heart distress.
I've heard several women say that when they had Pitocin.
Afterwards, the doctors reported that
the baby's heartbeat had slowed down. Yes,
Pitocin is a uterotonic drug,
so it causes contractions.
It goes from zero to 60 real fast.
So there's, like,
no early labor.
They can, like,
try and pretend mimic early labor,
but the contractions are strong no matter what
when you're on Pitocin.
So the baby doesn't get that natural, gradual,
we're doing labor now.
Mmm. They don't adapt well.